un contrôle surprise pour le centre
commercial westfield parly 2 objectif
veiller au respect du protocole
sanitaire renforcée face au co vite 19
donc le marquage au sol les affichages
préventif pour le basque obligatoire le
fait la distanciation et on s'assure
aussi que il n'y a pas de de
regroupement j'aime bien la jauge le
nombre de personnes présentes au sein du
magasin
plus personne ne rentre khabibulin
qu'elle n'ait pas mis des paniers la
visite se voulait pédagogique
elle vise à accompagner les commerçants
dans la mise en place du protocole les
règles de prévention sont strictes et
nous comprenons que pour les commerçants
grands ou petits ça suppose une
adaptabilité des personnes des clients
et cetera donc nous sommes là pour
accompagner cette respect des règles
encore une fois dans un esprit
pédagogique
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
mesures déjà mises en place une
application a notamment été développé
sur téléphone pour réguler le flux de
personnes en temps réel dans le centre
commercial
là on a le nom de personnes en présence
de ses trois mille neuf cent soixante et
une personnes
donc lorsqu'on attend en fait des seuils
critiques
on a donc des alertes donc le seuil il
est à 75% le 1er cei dans ces cas là
notre dispositif se met en place c'est à
dire que nos agents vont aux portes se
mettre en place pour commencé à filtrer
les entrées un nouveau passage surprise
aura lieu prochainement pour vérifier la
mise en place des mesures dans la
structure